[Applause]
that's a really good job by Jackson
instead of other without falling now on
the run for out a name we roam you got
contact we're gonna let it go
he'll take it we're gonna say he took
the back away on the night chance to
make a 32 at the line
[Applause]
corgis little will pick up Ingram as he
exits on the far side now he goes right
back to the rack and a step in fact it
were two and that just means to you
[Laughter]
Ingram why not
Austin was looking for contact he got a
mini where they inbounded it has Brandon
Ingram KOSDAQ gets it anyway he looks
back at Courtney Kerr boy
yeah but rubber right now you got to put
all the other stuff so drew gets a break
Ingram now the Seabees featured it's got
a nice little space for the mid-range 81
76
and using those six six seven these
event lazily when the year is over and
you look at the standings it's not going
to tell who was it wasn't playing art is
going to be there as a winner or loss
defend without falling and so you start
watching is some of the games what the
rules play you look at them right here
one dribble going right one or two
dribbles going right nice quickly it is
something Brandon Ingram six of the shot
clock as you look back together into the
floor going by Justin holiday lining to
the outside
[Music]
no rebound batted and controlled by
Kendrick Williams where's he been
he had 13 boards in the last meeting he
got new ones inside nice pass
Jackson Hays from ingre play this handle
crossover he's under the backboard stop
on a dime ball fate gets Glenn Robinson
the third up in the air good news his
scientist showing signs are starting to
be able to get back as Ingram works the
rebounds and takes the contact well
they're not a traditional dunk put it
that way no in a traditional because he
jumping over dude that six foot 10 to 80
yeah I like the that's impressive that
is impressive
cheating couple in the legal they just
had their first child I wonder how much
they talk officiating daddy would hope
not at all don't bring you were called